twitch's biggest con artist was exposed
and I'm here for the forensic analysis
look the crime has already been
committed it's already been confessed to
so we're not here for any of that
instead we're here to figure out how and
why I'm talking of course about Slicker
he's a famous live streamer who used his
connections with fans and other live
streamers to beg and borrow over 300 000
and never returned it and so I was up
all night talking to the victims of all
of this and their stories are wild and I
should start by saying I don't mean
Slicker is the biggest con artist in
terms of money like he didn't Rob Fort
Knox he didn't steal a famous painting I
mean the he's the biggest in terms of
the sheer number of victims who have
come forward I mean this guy was working
hard basically if you had a Twitch
account this guy came to you for money
but there are several extra details you
need to know as well as I said Slicker
already confessed I'm not Prosecuting
anything here I'm not alleging anything
here he admitted to everything last
night on a live stream after being
exposed by several fans and streamers
forgiveness but every single day I felt
guilty every single day I don't know
what to say to the people I borrowed
from every single day I was guilty
guilty in asking honestly I kind of
respect that he doesn't try to dispute
the facts here he just kind of owns up
to him and said yeah I did it yeah it
was bad but then after that it I kind of
get a problem with what he says when we
talk about why he did it because Slicker
says that he did all this because of a
gambling addiction he suffers from I
started to gamble with money and um
this was even when I started having my
first job and I used to gamble a lot of
my money uh basically all my twitch
money I and then even them times I
wouldn't even have them I'd come across
streamers and ask them if I could borrow
money I I don't know what to say but
this is the epitome of uh gambling uh I
will just I want to say that um
don't touch it man now look I do
honestly believe Slicker has a gambling
addiction I just don't think it explains
away everything in the way that he
thinks it does for example a gambling
addiction explains how Slicker lost his
money but it doesn't explain how he lost
everyone else's money or got it in the
first place I mean I feel like he's
trying to explain everything with the
story of like I have a gambling problem
but when you dig into the story you find
that Slicker isn't just a gambling
addict he's also a professional con
artist which we're gonna see in a second
so while he does need help he also needs
to face consequences because he played
an active role in all this it's like
meeting an alcoholic who you find out
broke into your house and cracked your
safe and they get caught at the police
station you go up to them and you say
how did you open my safe and they go oh
sorry
I'm an alcoholic you'd be like yeah but
how'd you crack open my safe and then
imagine they go oh well you know I just
can't stop drinking you'd be like okay I
don't think Jack Daniels taught you
these skills right so my point is yes
Slicker clearly has an addiction but he
also appears to be a professional con
man and we're going to talk about that
right now because I interviewed multiple
victims and created a master list of the
people who Slicker scammed because I
needed to get like a bird's eye view of
this thing there are over 55 people on
this list owed money right now and the
total scammed is over 384 thousand
dollars and what did I learn from these
55 people well there were a lot of
different ways Slicker like to approach
people but he really liked this Bank
scam method my buying account got locked
temporary locked don't have access to my
money sadly because
did UK Banks but whatever I was
wondering if I asked if I could borrow
money and I'd pay you back
now I'd even give you extra that's right
the old Frozen Bank trick basically go
to people and say hey look I can't
access my funds you you have to give me
money I'll pay you back I'll pay you
back even more and it's sort of
incredible to watch because not only is
all of this a lie but it's just so good
at acting ashamed like if I saw this I'd
believe you know oh man he's
petrified to ask me but come to find out
he's been telling everyone the same sob
story over and over again hey um I just
recently uh got into something with my
bank basically
um my bank account got locked this has
happened for like three four days yo Mo
I'm not hacked my bro I'm not so yeah
turns out he wasn't ashamed at all in
fact if you didn't believe him he would
even say other things like you know on
my mama when they didn't believe him or
he would swear on his religion that he
wasn't lying while lying listen to me
Nepali I swear I'm I'm a Muslim I swear
on the Quran I ain't lying I won't scam
you I'm gonna tell you on my mom's life
on my on my mom's life I'm not lying
please on my mom's life I know I know I
I know I understand I'm not lying I am
not lying I'm confident I'm not I
promise to God I'll have you month by
month you asked me 15th of next month
here you go 15th of a month here you go
here you go my mom's like do you think
I'm joking bro
I'm on mom's life I'm not bro I'm on
mom's life I'm not I absolutely cannot
stress enough just how many people he
used these tactics on to try to convince
them and it's interesting how he like
refined it over time right this is my
point about like professional con man
he's like a stand-up comedian who tries
his act in every city and like hones it
until he figures out exactly what to say
to make the audience laugh but he does
it for like scams like he knew the exact
script to use for example this is the
YouTuber umpaville who gave him a
thousand dollars but when he was asked
for another thousand uh he refused so he
said I got you on my mama he refused
again so Slicker sent him a document
from Bluestone Credit Management in
order to show how much he was in trouble
or whatever like he's basically saying
like I'm in trouble with taxes like you
got to help me out man I mean it's
genius because I'm pretty sure this
document is real he says bro legit tax
killed the F out of me which might be
true but come to find out this was a
document that he sent to several people
he recycled it over time which I found
out talking to another victim who hadn't
realized this yet and found it out in a
pretty amusing way every single time I
sent money it was for some reason that
made sense I sent it that much amount of
money because he got me in a call right
I just got home from my gym session gets
me to call and he's like yo he okay what
else he's breaking down he's almost on
the verge of tears he's breaking down
and he's like okay bro you're not gonna
believe this I didn't pay tax last year
and they and I'm owed 15.5 k
and listen she had the proof though so
this is the thing that doesn't make
sense though because I don't know if he
was lying to me he sent me a a document
he sent me the document nothing blurred
out nothing is on his lap I've seen his
room I just watched his stream so many
times so I can tell you this is 100
legit it's got his hairy ass arms in the
picture it says his name all the info
and the amount owed and it says that I
have the proof I think it's 15.3k to be
exact sorry 15.3k you know I've already
seen this screenshot but not from you
from someone else who got this oh no
letter I swear oh no I swear to you he
was sending it to every everybody he was
sitting into everybody
well this is news to me bro I did not
know this what I think is so crazy is
that Slicker scheme worked in part
because of how many people he was like
simultaneously lying to behind the
scenes and even though his tactics were
the same the exact story would sometimes
change based on the person so that it
took so long for people to figure out
which was explained to me by yet another
victim uh who found out because her
roommate was hearing a different story
than her and it made her curious why was
he getting asked for less money and with
a different story than her he'd asked me
for 5K in the video crying swimming on
the Quran on his parents where he pay me
back but then he's asked many Titan who
doesn't have as much money for 300
pounds tailored it specifically
to many knowing he has less liquid
income than me like and for mini it
wasn't like the story of like how he's
in debt with bad men it was what he had
an electric bill he needed to pay and he
was going to get cut off he made
different stories for different people
depending on how much he thinks he could
get out of them crazy to hear slicker's
scam exposed so well by someone who
never intended to expose him at all she
thought she was his friend her name is
lupeli and she was going through chemo
when she was scammed by this guy he did
this to you while you were going through
chemo well I was calling kuki Momo he
knew that he knew that while asking you
for money
yes so this is why I had no idea that I
was being scammed because first stuff I
met this person multiple times in person
um he knew I have a severe autoimmune
diseases while going through chemo he
calls me up and he is
so I am shaking thinking about it I
thought this guy was my friend and he
calls me up saying that he's gonna get
shout he owes people money and they're
outside like if he doesn't pay them then
like they're gonna break his legs and
I'm thinking
like I gotta help this guy you know I
was going through chemo I didn't think
I'm getting scammed by like my friend
like he's in a hard time I'm in a hard
time but I can help him
so I help him promises to pay me back
and he just doesn't guys if you don't
get it by now this guy will do and say
anything for money okay no bar is too
low if you're going after people in
chemo which is the reason why this
community needs to be very careful in
trusting Slicker ever again because
right now he's out there making the
apology to her saying how he plans to
pay everyone back but how can you trust
him it's a question that even he's aware
of I have to find a way to pay them back
but the funny thing is how can you trust
me how can you trust someone
[Music]
how could you trust someone like me what
I do find interesting about all of this
is it's just that listening to him
um you can kind of see why his victims
gave him money like he is compelling he
does sound so sincere but for many of
these victims it's interesting that
they've heard all this before this isn't
new like he kept saying no you don't get
it I you know I I I'm not lying to you
lupeli I'm not lying to you you know now
I know he was this is what subset me the
most like he knew he wasn't going to pay
back if I gave him the 10K he knew he
was lying about
having a loan from the bank which will
you know pay back what they give him he
was just giving me food
there it is that's my question to anyone
who thinks Slicker is suddenly gonna pay
everyone back that was true why wouldn't
he do that in the years that he was
borrowing from these people promising
then to pay them back but knowing he was
lying and yes I should say he did pay a
few people back okay but most of those
people I have to say he then asked for
more money and some of them he even like
fake paid back he's sending money back
sending money back I was like hello
hello uh he would be like yeah I can
send it I can send it and then he sent
me 1.7 K on PayPal but he sent it as a
transaction and then three days later it
was canceled so I never actually got any
of that money back truthfully the most
surprising thing about this whole
Scandal is just how well this is
reflected on the rest of the twitch
Community while also reflecting so bad
on Slicker and for this part I I just
wanted you to hear from one of slicker's
victims again he also showed me DMS
between him and Ludwig him and train Rex
Heyman such as a streamer of of him
dming them and then like asking for
money and then them not sending money
back but the worst part of it of all of
that is like he's so Shameless he would
talk them to me he'd be like bro you
don't understand streamers don't like
they're so money hungry they don't wanna
so ironic now looking at it but you're
like the stream is so money hungry they
don't want to help anyone out blah blah
blah blah and now after everything's
come out all these streamers sent him so
much money I cannot believe he said that
I cannot believe he came to my DMs and
told me yeah all these streamers are
just only care about his money you're
the ones who paid him all the money I
don't care I don't understand yeah you
know what it would have been better if
they were great honest honestly like the
biggest lesson from this is that like
slicker's terrible but then a lot of
streamers are actually good people like
they really want to help people out it's
like it's like the takeaway is not that
streamers aren't art uh are are really
not generous it's like if anything is
the opposite it's like they're two
chairs that's right if anything twitch
streamers just come off looking like
almost naively generous and while I say
that I actually have good news because
after this call that you just heard I
got a great update that I want to share
with you two of the biggest streamers
xqc and Ludwig both just pledged to
actually clean up slicker's mess and
refund all the people affected by the
scam which is amazing and proves my
point once again and while they're still
working on it I can confirm that lupeli
the woman we just heard from earlier has
actually already gotten her money back
so absolute credit where credit is due
guys that's an amazing thing another
interesting development from this is
that many people have used this as an
opportunity to call for the Banning of
twitch gambling streams which I
absolutely agree with especially
sponsored gambling streams I mean do I
think twitch will actually do something
from like mounting support and most
people being against it uh no no because
they make too many views and money but
do I think they should do it absolutely
it's a plague on the platform for
everyone who isn't the streamers who are
sponsored and making millions of dollars
right
so yeah that's basically where this
story stands make sure to give some love
to all the people who share their story
pump the stock send some money to my
frozen bank and I'll see you in the next
one